let's take the indefinite integral of
the square root of 7x plus 9 DX so my
first question to you is is this going
to be a good case for you substitution
when you look here we may be the natural
thing to set to be equal to U is 7 X
plus 9
but do I see its derivative anywhere
over here well let's see if we set u to
be equal to 7x plus 9 what is the
derivative of U with respect to X going
to be derivative of U with respect to X
is just going to be equal to 7
derivative of 7x is 7 derivative of 9 is
0 so do we see a 7 lying around anywhere
over here well we don't but what could
we do in order to have a 7 lying around
but not change the value of the integral
well the neat thing and we've seen this
multiple times is when you're evaluating
integrals scalars can go in and outside
of the integral very easily just to
remind ourselves if I have the integral
of let's say some scalar a times f of X
DX DX this is the same thing as a times
the integral of f of X DX that the
integral of the scalar times the
function is equal to the scalar times
the integral of the function so let me
put this aside right over here so with
that in mind can we multiply and divide
by something that will have a 7 showing
up well we can multiply and divide by 7
so imagine doing this let's rewrite our
original integral the original so let me
draw a little arrow here just to go
around that aside we could write our
original integral as being equal to the
integral of 1/7 times 7 times the square
root of 7x plus 9 DX and if we want to
we could take the 1/7 outside of the
integral we don't have to but we could
rewrite this as 1/7 times the integral
of 7 times the square root of 7x plus 9
DX so now if we set u equal
7x plus 9 do we have its derivative
laying around well sure
the 7 is right over here we know we know
that D u if we want to write in
differential form D U is equal to 7
times DX so D U is equal to 7 times DX
that part right over there is equal to D
U and if we want to care about you well
that's just going to be the 7x plus 9
that is our u so let's rewrite this
indefinite integral in terms of U it's
going to be equal to
it's going to be equal to 1/7 times the
integral of and I'll just take the 7 and
put it in the back so we could just
write the square root of u square root
of u D u 7 times DX is d u and we can
rewrite this if we want as u to the
one-half power it makes it a little bit
easier for us to kind of do the reverse
power rule here so we can rewrite this
as equal to 1/7 times the integral of U
to the one-half power D U and let me
just make it clear this u I could have
written in white if I want the same
color and this D U is the same d u right
over here so what is the antiderivative
of U to the one half power
well we increment to use power by one so
this is going to be equal to and let me
not forget this 1/7 out front so it's
going to be 1/7 times 1/7 times if we
increment the power year it's going to
be U to the three halves one half plus
one is one and a half or three halves so
it's going to be u to the three-halves u
to the three-halves and then we're going
to multiply the the this new thing times
the reciprocal of three halves which is
2/3 and I encourage you to verify the
derivative of 2/3 u to the three-halves
is indeed u to the one-half and so we
have that and since we're multiplying
1/7 times this entire indefinite
integral we could also throw in a plus C
right over here there might have been a
constant and if we want we can
distribute the 1/7 so it would get
1/7 times 2/3 is 2 over 21 2 over 21 you
to the three-halves and 1/7 times some
constant well that's just going to be
some constant and so I could write a
constant like that I can call that C 1
and then I could call this C 2 but it
really is just some arbitrary constant
and we're done oh actually no we aren't
done we still just have our entire thing
in terms of U so now let's unsubstituted
so this is going to be equal to 2 over
21 times u to the three-halves and we
already know it U is equal to U is equal
to 7x plus 9 we put a new color in here
just to ease the monotony so it's going
to be 2 over 21 times 7x plus 9 to the
three-halves power to the 3 halves power
plus C plus C and we are done we were
able to take a kind of hairy looking
integral and realize that even though it
wasn't completely obvious at first that
u substitution is applicable